pour ce jeu en fait faut juste prendre
la manette et la guinée dans le sens
inverse ok ils sont attentifs mais
connaissent déjà les règles du jeu les
jeunes gamers ne sont jamais vraiment en
vacances à saint quentin en yvelines sur
playstation 4 ou sur wii une dizaine
d'enfants s'opposer s'amusent pendant
plus d'une heure ce jour-là il incarne
notamment à rayman héros virtuel qui
doit sauver le monde face à mr d'arc et
peuvent aussi découvrir des nouveautés
plutôt ludique on arrive à connaître les
défauts ni les avantages on se parle en
plus homogène de tester un jeu très très
bien
ça pulse loire et en fait on y levant
les prends des pétales et on doit verdir
des endroits avec ses pétales sont
pratiques ce qui nous pas dangereux
j'ai beaucoup
je m'attends tout le monde ces ateliers
jeux vidéo sont proposés à chaque
vacances scolaires par le réseau des
médiathèques de l'agglomération à partir
de 6 ans et sans limite d'âge
l'occasion de jouer à plusieurs plutôt
que seuls à la maison
l'objectif c'est de passer un moment de
détente un moment de loisir et c'est
aussi découvrir le monde des jeux vidéo
alors qu'on propose des jeux sur notre
échelle des jeux sur la wii fit et on
sélectionne différents jeux il était
vraiment de jouer en groupe et aussi de
s'entraider dans le jeu l'inscription
pour participer à ces après midi est
obligatoire via le site internet des
médiathèques la prochaine session est
prévue pour mercredi 12 avril
non